[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
[Musique]
territoires merci d'être avec nous
directeur conseil chez odoxa et Francis
brochet qu'on est ravi d'accueillir
journaliste au groupe ébra les journaux
régionaux de l'Est de la France le
public le progrès les Dernières
Nouvelles d'Alsace pour ne citer que on
est ensemble parce qu'on va dévoiler les
résultats du baromètre mensuel au doxa
pour Public Sénat et la presse régionale
on verra la côte de popularité de
l'exécutif un ministre star de la
rentrée qui poursuit son ascension et la
sécurité qui remonte fortement dans les
préoccupations des Français et puis Alex
ce mois-ci le thème c'est la loi
immigration oui on verra ce que pensent
notamment les Français de du fameux
article 3 sur la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension on va ça tout de
suite d'abord on regarde actualité dans
nos
[Musique]
régions l'actualité dans nos régions du
côté de Lyon où on retrouve Alexis André
bonjour Alexis merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur de la publication de
Lyon Mag on va revenir avec vous sur ce
qui s'est passé dimanche soir à côté du
Vélodrome et ces incidents entre
l'Olympique de Marseille et l'Olympique
lonnais avec ce bus de l'OL ces bus de
l'OL qui ont été caayassés quelle est la
situation après ces incidents Alexis B
on peut dire qu'à Lyon la la silération
commence à laisser la place au aux
interrogations pour commencer vous
donner des des nouvelles des
protagonistes lyonnais hein les les
joueurs de l'OL qui sont rentrés dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi en avion ils
avaient ensuite un un jour de repos hier
et ils reprendront l'entraînement cet
après-midi à 15h les supporters qui ont
également été pris en cible les
supporters lyonnais et bien des cartes
substitution avaient été dépêché sur
place forcément pour eux ça a été plus
long certains sont rentrés hier à 8h du
matin et l'entraîneur Fabio Grosso qui a
été touché au au visage il a reçu des
éclats de de vitres et puis soit une une
canette ou une bouteille de de bière on
sait pas encore il va mieux mais il a
obtenu 30 jours d'ITT il devrait être
entendu par les les enquêteurs d'ici
vendredi et on sait pas encore s'il sera
sur le le banc de l'OL ce weekend pour
la réception du fcms alors quelles sont
les sanctions est-ce qu'il y a des
sanctions euh que risquent les deux
clubs alors pour pour moi orien il il y
a deux volets qui sont importants le
premier c'est évidemment à qui la faute
et très vite on a tous entendu le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald armanin
qui indiquait que c'était la Ligue que
c'était l'OM qui gérait le le dossier
que c'était vraiment le football était
responsable sauf que bien les policiers
qui escortent les bus les itinéraires
choisis et clairement celui de dimanche
était propice au guetapan et enfin
l'autorisation de laisser 600 supporters
lyonnais revenir à Marseille après 6 ans
d'interdiction et bien c'est la
préfecture des bouches du rô N et par
ricoch chez Bovo qui s'en occupe en tout
cas ça leur donne l'excuse rêvé pour
museler les les déplacements de
supporters partout en France à l'avenir
et puis le deuxième point et là c'est
absolument pas une une surprise pour
nous à Lyon ni pour le monde des ultras
et bien c'est la la présence de néonazis
de de facho chez les supporter de de
l'OL on a vu ces scènes honteuses dans
le parquage du Vélodrome et c'est pas
une une première parce que j'ai en
souvenir en 2018 à Manchester City et
bien en Ligue des Champions quand on
était encore en Ligue des Champions à
l'époque un supporter qui avait été
filmé en train de de faire un salut Naas
il avait été identifié appréhendé et et
viré des stades on a carrément un groupe
nonofficiel he qui se revendique de
cette mouvance la MedZ Lyon ils ont la
la Toten COP sur sur leur drapeau la
tête de mort DSS donc on peut imaginer
aussi que Marseille Lyon pour les
supporters c'est un peu transposé le le
combat ultra gauche ultra droite l'OL
qui doit faire le le ménage à la maison
mais aussi reprendre la main sur qui
participe au déplacement puisque le club
a les noms à les pédigré faut faut les
Balan lancé à la justice il faut que le
ménage soit fait en interne la parole en
tout cas commence à se libérer sur les
réseaux sociaux les réseaux sociaux
pardon chez les supporters lyonnais mais
on se doute bien donc que l'OL risque
d'être puni pour ce volet par par la
Ligue de de football on sait pas encore
en quoi ça pourrait consister mais l'OL
pourrait avoir des des points de de
suspension et quant à l'Olympique de
Marseille qui du coup pour cette
histoire n' n'a visiblement rien à se
reprocher mais il aura juste le match à
rejouer ce sera probablement à huclos et
probablement en décembre merci merci
beaucoup Alexis André directeur de la
publication de Lyon Mag on regarde la
Une de Lyon Mag de ce mois-ci et si on
faisait sauter Fourvière c'est à la Une
de votre journal merci Alexis André
Francis brochet vous connaissez
évidemment très bien euh Lyon euh est-ce
que vous êtes surpris de ce qui s'est
passé dimanche soir parce que on a
d'abord vu le caillassage de ce bus euh
par des Marseillais et puis après on a
appris ce qui s'est passé du côté des
supporters lyonnais avec euh ses ses
saluts néonazis notamment
écoutez je suis comme amateur de foot
déjà immensément triste et en colère je
pense que Lyon n'a pas le monopole de la
stupidité des supporters
malheureusement ni de la violence ce qui
m'a un peu sidéré c'est la réaction
extrêmement faible des autorités du
football cette réaction première
consistant à dire ça nous regarde pas
parce que c'était pas dans le stade que
je trouve d'une irresponsabilité totale
donc voilà après moi j'ai pas les
solutions mais je vous dis une immense
tristesse en tant qu'amoureux du
football ouais et ça fait ressurgir la
question de la de la violence dans le
sport a one question sociétal ou tout à
fait surtout qu'on partait pas de zéro
avec les supporters de de football on
avait fait un sondage il y a 2 ans sur
le sujet il y a deux Français sur trois
qui ont une mauvaise opinion des
supporters de football alors il les juge
majoritairement joyeux indispensable au
spectacle ils étaient contents du reste
de les voir revenir dans les stades
après l'époque du du covid pour autant
les Français jugent aussi
majoritairement qu'ils sont dans
dangereux majoritairement qui sont
idiots on arrive à un point aujourd'hui
où il y a ce qu'on mesurait plus d'un
Français sur deux ne sent pas en
sécurité dans un stade de football donc
c'est quand même un point important il y
a deux deux impacts il y en a à plus
long terme c'est pour l'image du
football et la pratique du football
c'est le premier sport pratiqué en
France puis il y a un deuxième impact à
plus court terme c'est pour la sécurité
des des Jeux Olympiques que ça peut
aussi inquiéter un peu les les Français
ce contexte ouais évidemment avec des
questions qui se posent un dernier mot
peut-être avec vous Francis brochet sur
Lyon qui est déjà un club en crise à
l'heure actuelle est-ce que tout ça ça
va rajouter une couche si je puis dire
ça on n sait rien ça peut ça peut avoir
l'effet contraire c'est ce que raconai
mes mes collègues du du Progrès de Lyon
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a eu une sorte de
d'effet de rassemblement devant
l'adversité donc à voir c'est vrai que
lu on traverse l'Olympique Lyonnais
traverse une très mauvaise
pass quelles seront les conséquences de
ces de ces ce Dr je franchement je n'en
sais rien j'allais dire enfin
rendez-vous sur le terrain c'est quand
même ce qu'il y a de plus important et
on suivra évidemment les les suites de
ces incident entre les deux olympiques
l'OM et l'OL on va parler du baromètre
baromètre mensuel au doxa pour Public
Sénat et la presse régionale comme tous
les mois Alex on commence par la côe de
popularité de l'exécutif comment se
porte-t-elle ce mois-ci et bien d'abord
on peut dire que la côe de popularité du
président de la République se porte
plutôt bien en tout cas elle progresse
il gagne deux points de popularité par
rapport au mois dernier pour 34 % des
français Emmanuel Macron est un bon
Président de la République en revanche
il n'y a toujours pas de dynamique pour
la première ministre éisabeth bornne qui
perd un point de popularité 30 % des
personnes interrogées considèrent que
c'est une bonne chef du gouvernement on
est quoi sur de la stabilité arwan
là-dessus on peut parler d'un d'un léger
rebond un léger rebond dans un contexte
quand même très spécifique qu'il faut
rappeler on a une crise au Moyen-Orient
une crainte importante des Français que
cette crise n'infuse sur le sol national
une hausse de la menace terroriste
ressentie après l'assassinat d'un
enseignant à haras donc on est quand
même sur un contexte d'opinion
particulier on a fait un sondage la
semaine dernière on voit que les
Français jugeaient important le
déplacement d'Emmanuel Macron au
Moyen-Orient pour rencontrer des des
chefs d'État et quiividait
particulièrement les deux prises de
position fortes de son de son
déplacement à savoir le soutien à Israël
dans sa lutte contre le terrorisme d'une
part et en même temps la conviction
qu'une paix durable ne se ferait que
dans une solution à deux états pour aant
voilà le rebond de popularité d'Emmanuel
Macron ce mois-i les deux points on est
quand même très en dessous alors qu'il
réendosse ses habits de président des
crises voilà mais on l'explique par le
contexte international c'est plus de
points ou pas oui tout à fait c'est
c'est c'est vraiment le le le rebond du
moment d'ailleurs on voit bien
qu'Élisabeth borne qui ne bénéficie pas
de la respiration d'une séquence
internationale voit sa popularité
stagner mais en tout cas alors qu'il
réendosse son habit de président des
crises on n pas du tout le rebond de
popularité qu'on a pu mesurer au moment
de la crise sanitaire au moment de la
crise ukrainienne on est à 34 % de
Français qui qui juge que c'est un bon
Président de la République c'est juste
quatre points au-dessus son niveau le
plus bas du prier semestre 2023 au plus
dur de la réforme des retraites donc on
voit les casserola don cess mais le la
popularité présidentielle n'a pas repris
autant de couleurs qu'elle n'en avait en
fin d'année 2022 Francis oui je pense
que c'est ce rebond il est moins
personnel que dû à la fonction
c'est-à-dire qu'on est dans une période
extrêmement tendue il est le président
de la République avec tout ce que ces
mots signifient et donc les Français
naturel se tourne vers lui comme comme
il s'était tourné il faut évoquer
d'autres moments extrêmement tragiques
dans notre histoire il s'était tourné
vers françois Hollande au moment de
l'attentat de Charlie et du Bataclan
François Hollande qui était dans une
popularité très dégradé avait à ces
moments-là retrouvé une certaine
popularité donc je crois que moi j'irais
pas plus loin si vous voulez ça parce
que sur le terrain diplomatique les deux
initiatives du président il faut le dire
aujourd'hui n'ont pas rencontré un grand
succès la ition humanitaire et la
coalition contre daesh ça ne reste que
des projets franco-français pour
l'essentiel quant à ellisabeth Borne
vous avez cité le terme de dynamique
j'allais dire la pauvre ne peut pas
avoir de dynamique la seule dynamique
qui existe en France c'est celle du
président donc elle n'a pas
d'espace alors elle montera d'un elle
descendra de deux mais enfin bon tout ça
restera extrêmement relatif et le jour
où le Président dit c'est fini B c'est
c'est fini alors comme tous les mois là
aussi on regarde le palmarè de
l'adhésion Alex il y a une personnalité
politique qui continue son ascension
Saint- Gabriel àal et oui le ministre de
l'éducation nationale passe de la 3e à
la deuxè place de ce baromètre de
popularité avec 36 % d'opinion favorable
c'est 4 points de plus que le mois
dernier le mois dernier on souvient il
avait fait une percée avec 11 points de
popularité supplémentaire devant lui il
y a toujours Édouard Philippe qui reste
l'homme politique préféré des Français
avec 40 % de bonnes opinions en 3e
position Marine Le Pen qui est suivi de
Jordan parela avec 29 % et Bruno leemire
28 % et quand on regarde précisément
l'adhésion du côté de la droite et bien
parmi les personnalités des républicains
les plus populaires on compte d'abord
Xavier Bertrand le président de la
région haute-fance avec 24 % de Français
qui ont de la sympathie pour lui ensuite
il y a le président du Sénat
jarardarchie qui connaît une bonne
dynamique he plus 6 points par rapport
au mois dernier avec 20 % juste devant
Laurent vquier 19 % le patron du parti
LR éc cotti 17 % et Bruno rotillo à 12 %
le président du groupe LR au Sénat ouais
Erwan alors la plus forte progression
euh dans les personnalités ce mois-ci
c'est Gérard Larché plus 6 points
comment l'explique alors on est dans un
contexte on va le voir un contexte
international qui a fortement heurté les
préoccupations des des Français et assez
logiquement comme il y a pu avoir un un
ralliment au drapeau avec un petit
soutien un peu à la hausse du du
Président on a un ralliment aussi des
sympathisants de la droite figure de ce
courant politique donc Gérard Larcher en
en profite c'est ce qu'on voit assez euh
régulièrement dans ce ce type de
contexte c'est quoi un effet post
sénatorial ou il est pour les sympathis
en droit celui qui rassemble plus non on
observe souvent dans les moments de de
crise internationale donc une reprise de
la popularité alors des chefs de l'État
d'ailleurs souvent c'est auprès des
personnes qui s'intéressent le moins à à
l'actualité politique et c'est une
espèce de de bienveillance qui se
renforce dans un contexte de de crise
mais on l'observe aussi pour les anciens
présidents les chefs de parti Gérard
Larché c'est le président du Sénat donc
il y il y a tous ces ces éléments qui se
cumule et donc on le voit d'ailleurs
dans la globalité des personnalités du
baromètre politique il y a une remontée
de popularité des codes d'adhésion des
figures de la droite ouais effectivement
remonté des figures de la droite et
toujours la montée de Gabriel Atal il
avait fait une percée spectaculaire le
mois dernier c'était 11 points si je me
souviens bien Erwan là il est encore à +
4 il est 2e derrière l'indétronnable
hdard Philippe à voir si ce n'est qu'une
bulle je veux dire Gabriel Atal il a il
est il est poli il est plutôt beau
garçon ils disent ce que la majorité
pense bon voir combien de temps ça
durera c'est un peu l'antimélanchon euh
donc ça ça assure son succès non moi ce
qui me frappe c'est que c'est que le le
champion de la popularité n'est que 40
% Édouard Philippe et je crois que c'est
Robert zarader qui avait fait le calcul
sur des sondages de popularité sur les
les 20 25 dernières années qui
constatait que la popularité moyenne
avait diminué de moitié
et on est là plutôt dans le constat de
de l'impopularité de nos responsables
politiques moi je trouve ça plutôt
préoccupant ouais c'est pas le plus
populaire hdard Philippe c'est le moins
impopulaire oui c'est c'est le moins
impopulaire oui mais parce qu'on on est
passé aussi d'un système essentiellement
bipartisan à des préférences politiques
qui sont beaucoup plus éclatées
aujourd'hui tripolarisé ou
quadripolarisé ce qui fait que on est
dans un contexte où avec les trois
grands blocs de du paysage politique
national
finalement avoir un/ers des Français qui
qui vous soutiennent ça signifie que
vous faites quand même le le plein de de
de soutien dans votre cors mais c'est
vrai que cette configuration est un peu
particulière et que le la barre des 50 %
apparaît comme un Graal plutôt que comme
un un accès site très accessible pour
Gabriel Atal c'est c'est quand même
impressionnant de voir que dans un
contexte où justement les positions
politiques des Français sont assez
sédimentés son passage de Bercy à
l'éducation nationale a encore élargi la
la base de ses soutiens on voit qu'il a
progressé notamment auprès des
sympathisants PS et auprès des
sympathisants LR mais aussi auprès des
sympathisants Renaissance il avait une
côte d'adhésion de deux personnes sur
trois il fait l'unanimité maintenant il
y a quand même une popularité qui s'est
élargie qui s'est peut-être accompagné
du sentiment d'autorité d'engagement
autour de la polémique sur les les
abaillard il y a la question de la
sécurité des établissements aujourd'hui
il y a eu le harcèlement scolaire donc
c'est un ministre qui au premier plan
continue à élargir ses soutiens c'est un
point important parce que les ministres
qui qui nouvellement nommé voit plutôt
le leur soutien se se réduire donc c'est
quand même à signaler pour autant il a
une côte de popularité moins solide
aujourd'hui que celle d'Édouard Philippe
qui est plus transversale alors que
celle de Gabriel hatal reste assez
clivée beaucoup porté par les Français g
de 65 ans et plus des métropoles et
desad et les cadres on va passer aux
thématiques euh quelles sont les
thématiques les plus importantes pour
les Français ce mois-ci Alex et bien le
pouvoir d'achat reste toujours en tête
des préoccupations des Français c'est un
sujet important pour 50 7 % des
personnes interrogées la santé également
pour 45 % des Français et puis sans
surprise après l'attentat d'arace la
sécurité et la lutte contre le
terrorisme font un bon et préoccupent ce
mois-ci 39 % des Français c'est 13
points de plus que le mois dernier
l'immigration a aussi de l'importance
pour 30 % de nos compatriotes c'est plus
6 points on précise juste qu'il y avait
trois réponses possibles d' ces scores
qui sont nettement supérieurs à 100 % AW
percée fulgurante j'allais dire des
thématiques sécurité et immigration oui
tout à fait alors avec la sécurité qui
est un un sujet qui est quand même très
sensible à l'actualité donc plus 13
points c'est une hausse importante mais
sécurité lutte contre le terrorisme dans
le contexte actuel on le comprend
immigration plus 6 points mais des
hausses beaucoup plus importantes auprès
des sympathisants LR et rassemblement
national pour qui c'est un point
important autrement dit les personnes
qui sont les plus attentif aux questions
d'immigration renforce encore leur
attention sur ce sujet faut préciser
aussi que ça se fait au détriment de
deux thématiques qui baissent
l'éducation et l'environnement et la
sécurité et l'immigration faut aussi
avoir en tête que c'est des points sur
lesquel Emmanuel Macron peine à généré
de la crédibilité politique moins que
ses concurrents et notamment que Marine
Le Pen quand on évaluer la capacité des
deux sur ces sujetsl au moment de
l'entre de tour on voyait bien que elle
partait avec de l'avance dans dans
l'opinion donc il y a un essai à
transformé pour Emmanuel Macron sur ces
sujets qui reviennent au premier plan
alors même que le la loi immigration
arrive en débat ouais on va en parler
Francis si je puis me permettre je je ne
partage pas votre analyse
euh il s'est passé quand même des choses
extrêmement grave euh la mort
l'assassinat de de ce professeur qui
nous a tous choqué Bernard euh la guerre
à Gaza qui dure avec toutes ces horreurs
et et la sécurité la lutte contre le
terrorisme ne reste que 3è je veux dire
c'est ça moi qui me paraît important euh
malgré tout cela le pouvoir d'achat
reste à 57 % le premier sujet de
préoccupation des Français la santé on
sent que c'est une réponse plus
personnelle chacun est inquiet pour sa
santé mais c'est quand même le pouvoir
d'achat qui reste la première
préoccupation et je crois qu'il faut pas
l'oublier il est parfaitement naturel
que dans la période la sécurité le
terrorisme soit soit en progression mais
n'oublions pas le pouvoir d'achat quand
à l'immigration c'est pareil je veux
dire ça fait 6 mois que l'on parle
énormément d'immigration et ça n'est que
30 % que 30 % enfin excusez-moi je je
prends à l'envers votre analyse mais
mais je crois qu'il faut voir ça aussi
l'immigration est plus un sujet
politique qu'un sujet des Français Erwan
oui oui tout à fait je pense que il y a
ce ce point là qui est intéressant à
rappeler justement cette place du
pouvoir d'achat qui est continuellement
sondage après sondage depuis 2 ans la
préoccupation numéro 1 des Français
d'ailleurs sur les questions de sécurité
c'est intéressant de de voir que la
question de l'immigration elle est très
importante chez les sympathisants
rassemblement national et l'autre
préoccupation qui est très importante
pour eux c'est le pouvoir d'achat chez
les sympathisants LR on a l'immigration
qui est très importante aussi mais le
pouvoir d'achat plus bas c'est la
sécurité qui arrive sur le le duo des
préoccupations donc il y a un vrai poid
du pouvoir d'achat qui plus est chez les
sympathisants r mais ça veut dire juste
cette montée que c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle politique pour Emmanuel Macron
parce que c'est des sujets vous nous le
dites où il est pas où il est pas
reconnu comme le plus crédible alors il
est pas en position de de force dans le
contexte actuel c'est ce que ce qu'on
disait aussi que l'immigration est un
sujet éminemment politique en tout cas
il y a non seulement un équilibre à
trouver à l'Assemblée mais aussi une
crédibilité sur laquelle il va falloir
rassurer les Français sur la capacité à
prendre les bonnes mesures pour faire
face au problèmes qui se posent en
France aujourd'hui alors tout ça au
moment où le projet de loi immigration
arrive au Sénat ce sera lundi prochain
Alex comment est perçu ce projet de loi
immigration par les Français et bien 41
% des Français pensent que ce projet de
loi immigration va permettre de mieux
contrôler l'immigration seulement 22 %
estime qu'il va améliorer l'intégration
des personnes immigrées mais d'ailleurs
quelle est la priorité des Français
entre ces deux objectifs de ce texte et
bien 72 % des Français estiment que
l'objectif le plus important c'est
d'abord de mieux contrôler l'immigration
27 % Pench pour l'amélioration de
l'intégration et enfin sur la mesure qui
fait débat dans ce texte le fameux
article 3 sur la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension et bien 55 % des
Français sont pour cette mesure donc
quand le gouvernement quand le ministre
de l'Intérieur geréraldarmanin affirme
qu'il veut conserver l'article 3 dans ce
texte et bien en fait il se conforme à
l'opinion d'une majorité de Français
ouais une majorité de Français est
d'accord du coup avec la ligne du
Gouvernement sur ce projet de loian oui
tout à fait bah ce qu'on observe c'est
que déjà les les Français sont beaucoup
plus favorables à mieux contrôler
l'immigration qu'à améliorer
l'intégration des immigrés c'est c'est
un point important parce que c'est bon
c'est un sujet très tranché c'est chez
sympathisants Renaissance et
rassemblement national très s favorable
à mieux contrôler l'immigration mais
même les sympathisants de la gauche sont
assez partagés finalement ils sont
quasiment à 5050 entre mieux contrôler
l'immigration et améliorer l'intégration
des des immigrés ça montre à quel point
le curseur s'est déplacé vers la droite
sur ces sujets d'immigration et sur le
titre de séjour métier en tension c'est
particulièrement notable ça fait
beaucoup moins débat dans l'opinion des
Français que ça ne le fait dans la
classe politique les Français ils sont
favorables avec vraisemblablement une
prime à la compétitivité économique
c'est-à-dire que dans un contexte où les
Français savent que l'État est endetté
et doit améliorer les les indicateurs
sur le plan de l'économie il est
important probablement de redonner un
coup de boost au marché de l'emploi à
travers cette mesure ouais Francis sur
ce projet de l' immigration moi ce que
j'ai noté et c'est très bien que vous
l'ayz signaler dans le dans la
présentation de votre sondage c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de Français qui ne
savent pas ce qu'il y a dans le projet
de loi c'est-à-dire que je crois de
mémoire 39 % ne savent pas quelles sont
les mesures favorisant la lutte contre
l'immigration et 40 7 % ne connaissent
pas les mesures euh facilitant
l'intégration ça veut dire que tout ce
débat et on revient au 30 % de de
Français qui estiment que c'est le sujet
le plus important tout ce débat n'a que
partiellement
atteint l'opinion publique l'ensemble de
l'opinion publique et je ce qui me
frappe aussi dans ce ce projet de loi et
d'une certaine manière avec votre
sondage vous mettez en avant le en même
temps de du gouvernement hein un peu de
lutte contre l'immigration un peu de euh
de favorisation de favoriser
l'intégration mais mais ce projet est
toujours à la recherche de sa ligne
c'est un peu comme le le projet sur les
retraites c'est-à-dire ça fait quand
même plus d'un an qu'il a été proposé et
depuis plus d'un an il passe d'un côté à
l'autre alors un moment on met en avant
l'intégration un moment on met en avant
la lutte contre l'immigration et il n'a
toujours pas trouvé son point
d'atterrissage
euh donc c'est ça qui pose un peu
question par rapport au au pouvoir à
Emmanuel Macron que veut-il vraiment h
sur ce en même temps par finalement
c'est en même temps ce projet de loi
immigration est-ce qu'il est vraiment
tenable c'est ça la question ben pour
l'instant oui on se on se pose la
question et on a l'impression quand même
on sent quand même que la tendance est
plutôt à conserver la substance de
l'article 3 c'est-à-dire de permettre à
ces personnes sans papier mais qui ont
un travail d'être régularisé c'est la
tendance sauf que on ne veut pas
l'affirmer politique ement donc on le
ferait passer par une autre voix c'est
ce que je crois comprendre de de tout ce
qu'on entend ce sondage il est
intéressant car si on pose l'hypothèse
de l'utilisation du 493 sur ce projet de
loi immigration c'est-à-dire que le
gouvernement passerait en force sur ce
texte à l'Assemblée nationale comme il
l'a fait sur la réforme des retraites
quand on prend l'exemple de la réforme
des retraites et bien le gouvernement
avait l'opinion contre lui si on regarde
ce sondage là sur ce texte immigration
et bien les Français ils sont plutôt
favorables avec une forme de en même
temps à la fois mieux contrôlé et puis
oui pour régulariser et intégrer les
travailleurs sans papier donc ça peut
être un argument pour le gouvernement
pour utiliser le 493 et aussi pour
essayer de ramener les voix de la droite
des républicains en leur disant bah
c'est très bien votre discours
d'opposition frontale à cette
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier mais regardez il y a une majorité
de Français qui sont pour donc si vous
ne voulez pas le voter bien nous on va
passer en force car on se conforme à
l'opinion publique donc ça c'est c'est
un argument de poids pour le
gouvernement bonne nouvelle pour pour le
gouvernement mauvaise nouvelle pour les
républiquins
euh oui et non parce que en en réalité
dans l'arbitrage stratégique si
ellisabeth borne doit discuter de
l'acceptabilité du projet avec les
républicain et avec la possibilité de
retirer l'article 3 le projet ne
perdrait pas vraisemblablement de son
soutien dans l'opinion si l'article 3
était retiré on voit que les Français
penchent quand même largement plus pour
un contrôle accru de l'immigration que
pour une amélioration de l'intégration
des immigrés que ce qu'on a testé nous
aussi le le mois dernier c'est les
mesures proposées par Bruno re et on
voit que 7 Français sur 10 sont
favorables à la suppression de laame à
l'instauration de cotas migratoire au
Parlement à le à la la au dépôt de la
demande d'asile dans les pays d'origine
ou dans des des pays tiers à à
l'accélération des OQTF donc on a quand
même tous ces signaux là qui montrent
que quoi qu'il arrive l'aspect contrôle
accru de l'immigration serait soutenu
par la population bien sûr c'est c'est
un projet destiné à la droite quand on
le voit dans dans dans votre sondage
aussi le projet intéresse d'autant plus
qu'on est plus à droite c'est assez
linéaire plus on est à droite et à
forceorie quand on est au rassemblement
national on est passionné par le sujet
et quand on est écologiste ou l fille on
est beaucoup moins donc c'est cette
frange là de l'opinion que cherche le
pouvoir et et c'est là où vous avez
raison je veux dire ça sera d'autant
plus facile de de faire passer à 493 et
ça sera d'autant plus compliqué pour LR
que une grande partie de l'électorat de
droite sera content de ce projet surtout
si le fameux article 3 passe passe par
la goutière Francis sur cet article sur
les métiers en tension alors on l'a dit
les Français sont majoritairement
favorables mais si on regarde les
sympathisants républicains ils sont
seulement 49 % et être favorable et
surtout c'est moins 10 points par
rapport au au mois précédent est-ce que
ça ça va jouer forcément dans la
tactique des des alr c'est-à-dire faut
voir la cause et la conséquence est-ce
que il y a moins 10 % parce que
l'électorat évolue ou parce que tous les
leaders etir ont
martelé l'extrême dangérosité de cet
article
3 qui de l'œuf ou la poule c'est PL
c'est plutôt le deuxième cas en général
on a tendance dans les sondages à voir
le soutien refluer dès lors que les
sujets sont débattus on l'avez vu avec
le mariage pour tous ça n'a rien à voir
mais c'est assez caractéristique c'estàd
que les Français étaient majoritairement
favorables avant que le le sujet ne soit
introduit législativement et les les
opinions se sont beaucoup plus polarisé
une fois que ça a été débattu il veut
dire que la politique sert à quelque
chose voilà donc le débat politique a
vraisemblablement renforcé la vigilance
des sympathisants aler qui sont tout de
même un sur deux à soutenir la création
de ce ce titre de séjour métier en
tenstion donc il y a quand même une
opinion qui est beaucoup moins
conflictuel sur ce sujet que la classe
politique ouais sur sur la classe
politique on a vu les les côtes de
popularité qui montent à droite
notamment celle de Gérard Larché celle
de Gérald armanin qui reste quand même
assez élevée par rapport au reste il est
7e dans dans votre classement il gagne
un point est-ce que du coup qui
politiquement est en position de force
dans le match qui s'annonce la semaine
prochaine pour l'instant plutôt plutôt
Géral hermanin plutôt leslr pour
l'instant c'est le gouvernement et
l'exécutif qui sont quand même nettement
plus soutenu par l'opinion les LR ce qui
leur manque aujourd'hui c'est un espace
politique entre un tiraillement vers le
centre droit et un tiraillement vers
l'extrême droite c'est un ADN politique
sur ces questions d'immigration avec un
choix stratégique qui a opéré pour eux
est-ce qu'il doivent être influents dans
le projet de l'exécutif ou dans une
motion de censure et dans une
contreprosition législative ça ça tient
plus à l'arbitrage de leur part mais
dans un contexte où on le disait les
Français sont quoi qu'il arrive
majoritairement favorable aux mesures de
durcissement contre l'immigration et
donc le l'exécutif a l'opinion avec lui
ouais le point va l'exécutif Francis
franchement je n'en sais rien je dire je
crois qu'il faut il faut attendre il
faut attendre les votes et au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée il faut pour pour savoir qui
sortira s'il y a un vainqueur de de
cette très très longue histoire parce
que quand même encore une fois ça fait
plus d'un an qu'on est sur le sujet mais
ça ça veut quand même dire si on si on
suit votre sondage que les Français ils
attendent quand même un texte
immigration et et ils attendent un
durcissement finalement un meilleur
contrôle de l'immigration est-ce que si
leslr bloque le texte et empêche
l'adoption de cette loi ça serait
mauvais po pour eux ça dépend comment ça
sera interprété euh que les Français
spontanément disent il faut mieux
contrôler l'immigration n'est pas une
surprise je veux dire je pense que toute
personne rencontrée dans la rue dira oui
oui il faut mieux contrôler et puis en
même temps parce qu'on a tous nos
contradictions ila et puis il faudrait
mieux intégrer donc après c'est comment
on traduit ça politiquement et et il y a
beaucoup de mesures qui pourront ensuite
une fois qu'elles seront dans le débat
précisément que les gens les auront
vraiment comprises pourront créer un
débat peut-être plus plus
tendu pour concl l'obstruction
parlementaire est pas particulièrement
appréciée des des Français on l'a vu
avec la réforme des retraites pas
seulement sur le tumulte à l'Assemblée
mais même sur le nombre d'amendements
déposés en général le sentiment qu'une
procédure était retardé sur un sujet qui
est qui est attendu ça dessert quand
même ceux qui font le un peu
d'obstruction voilà on suivra évidemment
ces débats à partir de lundi prochain au
Sénat avant de se quitter on regarde ce
qu' a la une de nos journaux régionaux
avec
Alex
[Musique]
Alex on commence par les suites de
l'attaque du bus de l'Olympique lonais
par les supporters marseillais et oui le
football toujours malade de la violence
titre le journal Le Républicain Laurin
la gangraine titre le journal
marseillais la Provence La Provence qui
s'intéresse aujourd'hui sur le profil de
ces supporters marseillais qui ont pris
part au cillassage du bus lyonnais qui a
fait 15 blessés ce sont des supporters
indépendants issus de la mouvance
radicale la plupart n'appartient à aucun
groupe officiel de supporter et lors des
matchs et bien il se rassemble dans les
rues de la ville et cherche la violence
la confrontation avec les supporters
adverses ces indépendants il seraient
quelques centaines à Marseille
actuellement le journal Le Progrès de
Lyon fait sa Une également sur ses
violence l'ancien joueur de l'Olympique
Lyonais syiddney govu estime dans le
journal Le Progrès qu'il existait des
signaux pour voir ce qui allait arriver
quand on observe la violence des
supporters ces dernières années avec
notamment et bien des supporters
lyonnais l'année dernière qui avait
failli rentrer dans le vestiaire pour se
battre avec un joueur et justement ces
supporterurs Lyonnais sont également
dans le viseur puisque certains ont été
filmés dimanche soir au Vélodrome en
train de faire des salut naziis et
d'onner des champs homophobes elle a une
de Corse Matin un rapport sur la mafia
et oui après 5 mois de travaux et de
consultation des collectifs de citoyens
et des associations antimafia la
présidente de l'Assemblée de Corse
Marie-Antoinette mopertui a livré un
premier rapport sur les dérives
mafieuses dans l'île un rapport qui
propose davantage Tage de contrôle
juridique pour éviter que la mafia
n'infiltre des secteurs straté
stratégiques de l'économie il propose
également des actions envers la jeunesse
et l'organisation d'une conférence
permanente pour lutter contre ces
dérives mafieuses un rapport qui est
jugé insuffisant par les associations
c'est le début du mois sans tabac et
c'est à la Une de certains quotidiens
régionaux oui c'est à la Une du journal
Le Populaire du centre et du journal Le
Midi Libre 110000 personnes se sont déjà
inscrites à cette initiative du mois
sans tabac sur le site internet moi sans
tabacinoservice.fr alors on le rappelle
he chaque participant est mis en
relation avec un spécialiste un
tabacoloque pour arrêter de fumer et il
faut savoir que les fumeurs qui
participent à cette initiative ont cinq
fois plus de chanceces d'arrêter de
fumer en France on le rappelle un/4 des
Français entre 18 et 75 ans euh fument
encore aujourd'hui quotidiennement et
puis notez aujourd'hui qui arrêtz de
fumer bien c'est remboursé par la
Sécurité Sociale en Occitanie l'an
dernier 6 millions d'euros ont été
dépensés pour rembourser des traitements
nicotinique de substitution on termine
par la toussin et la fête des morts et
sud-ouest s'intéresse au secteur
funéraire ah oui les journalistes de
Sud-Ouest sont allés à la rencontre de
professionnels du secteur et notamment
de Philippe Labéguerie qui dirige une
entreprise de pompe funèbre dans le
département des Landes et il le dit he
je le cite la mort est un des grands des
derniers grands tabou de notre société
elle provoque souvent le silence et il
raconte l'utilité de son métier pour les
famille et l'intérêt de le faire depuis
plus de 25 ans on a beau connaître et
maîtriser les usages unee prestation
n'est identique nous ne savons pas à
quoi va ressembler notre journée et puis
Philippe laabgerie quand il est en
société dans les repas et bien son
métier suscite beaucoup de questions
notamment sur les personnes qui seraient
enterrées vivantes he les légendes il le
dit après plus de 15000 enterrement il
nen a jamais vu merci merci Alex pour
cette revue de presse on revit la une du
progrès Francis et c'est les suites de
ces incidents entre l'OM et l'OM il y
avait des signaux sur ce qui allait
arrivriver merci beaucoup franc Bret
d'avoir été avec nous mercian pour ce
baromètre mensuel on vous retrouve le
mois prochain évidemment merci Alex
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi nous on
se retrouve jeudi pas d'émission demain
exceptionnellement et on vous souhaite
une très bonne
journée